hallo liebe freunde der grünwald
freitags comedy wir gehen jetzt alle in
den osterurlaub unter kreimer und sehr
drauf weil wir uns wirklich verdient ja
vorher möchte allerdings welcher song in
eigener sache
ich möchte in meiner sendung ein bisserl
weniger albern zeigt das ist ich hab das
kultige blödeleien dem ein bisschen
überhand genommen und ich komme es doch
immer alter mann entschuldigung bin
letzte woche bus gefahren dass er alte
frau für mich aufgestanden und das hat
man schon zu denken gegeben ich glaube
es wird wirklich zeit dass ein bisschen
bisschen seriöser der weg von diesen
alba rein und aber na ja gut das wird ja
bloß song dann wünsche ich ihnen frohe
ostern bis zur nächsten sendung